>> Jesse: A VIDEO SHOWS WORLD
LEADERS LAUGHING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEHIND HIS BACK.
ALTHOUGH THEY MAY JUST BE
LAUGHING AT THE VOTERS WHO
ELECTED HIM.
ISN'T THAT ADORABLE?
THE TOUR GUIDES AT EPCOT CENTER
HANG OUT OFF DUTY.
JUST A FEW REGULAR WORKING STEP
SHOOTING THE BREEZE, HOW CUTE.
NOW TRUMP IS CALLING A TRUE NOTE
TO FACE WHICH IS A STEP UP FROM
BEING BLACK FACE.
HE SHOULD BE RED-FACED.
BUT ALL THE EMPLOYEES TALK ABOUT
THEIR BOSS BEHIND THEIR BACK AND
IN WORLD AFFAIRS, TRUMP AS THEIR
BOSS AND THEIR MIDDLE MANAGERS
OPERATING FRANCHISES UNDER HIS
WATCHFUL EYE.
THEY DON'T TALK BEHIND THE BACKS
OF INCONSEQUENTIAL JERKS SO
TRUDEAU STILL HAS NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT.
JUST WATCH THIS BACK AND FORTH.
>> PUT THEM ON A PAYMENT PLAN.
WHAT IS YOUR NUMBER?
>> THE NUMBER WE TALKED ABOUT A
70% INCREASE OVER THESE PAST
YEARS INCLUDING AND FOR THE
COMING YEARS SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FIGHTER JETS,
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN OUR
NAVAL FLEETS, WE ARE INCREASING
SIGNIFICANTLY OUR DEFENSE
SPENDING FROM PREVIOUS
GOVERNMENTS THAT CUT IT.
>> OKAY, WHERE YOU NOW IN TERMS
OF YOUR NUMBER?
>> Greg: WHAT A NICE LITTLE
BOY.
WAS LIKE AN EPISODE OF
"CELEBRITY APPRENTICE," WORLD
LEADERS ADDITION AND YOU SAW HOW
OBEDIENT THE CONTEST AND WAS.
TRUMP SHOULD HAVE GIVEN HIM A
COOKIE OR SOME SHOE POLISH.
HE TOLD HIM TO BRING THE LIMO
OUT FRONT.
BUT THAT IS LIFE, EVERY BOSS
GOOD AND BAD, IT IS A NECESSARY
FUNCTION THAT UNITES UNDERLINGS
WHO NEED TO VENT WHEN THE BIG
KAHUNA IS AROUND AND THAT THE
BURDEN OF BEING THE BIG KAHUNA
BUT AT THE END OF THAT SILLY DAY
AFTER SCHOOLING THESE
CHEAPSKATES OVER MONEY THEY'VE
OWED AND RESPONSIBILITIES
THEY'VE IGNORED, HE REALLY STILL
IS THE BOSS WHO WORKS FOR US AND
NOT THEM.
I HAVE TO SAY, I FOUND THE
TWO-FACED JOKE TO BE GENIUS
BECAUSE IT MAKES YOU THINK THAT
TRUDEAU IS LITERALLY TWO-FACED.
>> Shannon: HE DEFINITELY DID
NOT SHY AWAY FROM TAKING IT
FACE-TO-FACE, NO PUN INTENDED
AND I THINK AS THE MEDIA IS
FOCUSING ON THIS AND THE
CHILDISH ASPECT OF WHAT THESE
WORLD LEADERS DEAD, THE REALITY
IS THAT SOME IT WAS A SUCCESS.
AND IN GENERAL FOR THE ENTIRE
NATO ALLIANCE, IT WAS A BIG DEAL
THAT HE BACKED AWAY FROM HIS
THREAT TO STOP THE INCREASED
DEFENSE SPENDING TOWARDS THE
BALTIC STATE IN POLAND.
IT'S A BIG DEAL THAT ALL 29
MEMBER STATES CAME TOGETHER
BASICALLY AGAINST RUSSIA TO
INCREASE THAT SPENDING AND IT IS
A BIG DEAL I THINK THAT TRUMP
GOT THAT COMMITMENT WITHOUT MORE
CONCILIATORY TONE WENT UP UNTIL
NOW, EVERYONE HAS BEEN BLASTING
HIM FOR SAYING YOU WERE JUST
THREATENING ALL THE OTHER STATES
SO I THINK THIS KIND OF
REPRESENTS A NEW AND IMPROVED
NATO AND A NEW AND IMPROVED
APPROACH TO IT.
BUT WE ARE GETTING A LOT.
>> Juan: LETS GO BACK TO HIS
RESPONSE, TWO-FACED.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT?
>> Jesse: SHOULD HAVE BEEN
THREE-PHASE.
>> Juan: THE REASON I AM SO
CURIOUS ABOUT THIS AS EVERYONE
SAYS YOU DEMOCRATS ARE SUCH
SNOWFLAKES, WHO WAS THE
SNOWFLAKE NOW?
TALK ABOUT OVERLY SENSITIVE.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT BE
TAKING EVERYTHING SO PERSONALLY.
HE'S THE ONE THAT RESPONDED WITH
THE TWO-FACED COMMENTS.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND, THEY CAN SAY ALL
THEY WANT, HE IS STILL THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD AND THE
LEADER OF THE U.S., BUT HE
REACTS AS IF IT'S ALL ABOUT ME.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT THAT WAS A
GREAT RESPONSE BECAUSE IT BRINGS
BACK THE WHOLE CONTROVERSY.
>> Juan: GOING TO CREATE MORE
ANIMOSITY GOING FORWARD.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE OVERHYPING
IT.
THEY WEREN'T MAKING FUN OF HIM,
THEY WERE GOSSIPING ABOUT HIM.
YOU GOSSIP ABOUT TWO PEOPLE, YOU
GOSSIP ABOUT YOUR BOSS AND
CELEBRITIES.
YOU SHOULD HEAR WHAT THEY SAY
ABOUT ME.
I GOT YOUR OFFICE WIRED.
HERE'S THE DEAL, HE DOES WHAT HE
WANTS AND THEY HAVE TO REACT TO
IT.
THEY ARE LIVING IN HIS WORLD.
TRUMP WANTS TO TAKE 40 MINUTES
QUESTIONS, THEY HAVE TO SIT
THERE LIKE LITTLE BOYS AND DO
IT.
HE WAS COMPLAINING THAT HE WAS
LATE FOR COCKTAILS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT, WE HAVE ALL
BEEN THERE.
HE NEEDS A BREAK AFTER THE
BLACKFACE SCANDAL.
THE POINT IS THEY ARE AT HIS
MERCY AND HE IS THE BOSS.
>> Greg: JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY
PICKED UP ON THIS AND LET'S ROLL
THAT.
>> WORLD LEADERS CAUGHT ON
CAMERA LAUGHING ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> SEVERAL WORLD LEADERS MOCKING
>> THEY ARE LAUGHING AT HIM.
MY ADMINISTRATION HAS
ACCOMPLISHED MORE THAN ALMOST
ANY ADMINISTRATION IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: I THINK IT IS AN
EFFICIENT ADD BUT THE WORLD IS
NOT JUST LAUGHING AT TRUMP, THEY
ARE LAUGHING AT AMERICA IS WHAT
THAT AD IS SAYING.
>> Shannon: HE TALKS A LOT
ABOUT HIS FOREIGN POLICY TRAPS
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPPORTERS OF
HIM DO.
HE HAD TWO FORMER DEFENSE
SECRETARY SET OF BOTH TALKED
ABOUT HOW NOT GOOD HE WAS AT
FOREIGN POLICY.
GATES SAID HE WAS WRONG ON
NEARLY EVERY FOREIGN POLICY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE IN THE
PAST FOUR DECADES TALKING ABOUT
BIDEN.
THEY WANT TO GO THERE, RATED
GATES MOSTLY TRUE ON THE WAY
THEY WERE ASSESSING BIDEN.
SO IF HE WANTS TO GO FOREIGN
POLICY, HE NEEDS TO BE PREPARED
THAT WILL BE PLENTY OF CRITICS
WHO COME AFTER HIM.
>> Juan: IF YOU ASK ABOUT THE
INCUMBENT, NOT SUCH NICE.
>> Jesse: ASKED AL-BAGHDADI.
>> Juan: ASKED THE DOG.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA GRABBED THE
STORY BECAUSE NONE OF THE PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA ARE USED TO BEING
MANAGERS OR BOSSES.
THEY ARE ALL JOURNALISTS.
WHEN YOU MANAGE ANYTHING, THEY
ARE PEOPLE IN THE MAIL ROOM AND
WHERE ELSE THAT WILL TALK ABOUT
YOU.
>> Juan: HAVE YOU GONE
OVERSEAS AND REALIZE MOST OF THE
WORLD DOESN'T UNDERSTAND TRUMP?
>> Greg: I LOVE THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE RULED BY
MR. POPULAR.
I WANT THEM TO BE SCARED OF HIM.
>> Juan: RIGHT.
>> Jesse: PROBABLY LAUGHING
WHEN HE WAS BOWING.
>> Juan: PEOPLE THREW A SHOE
AT GEORGE W BUT THEY WOULD NEVER
LAUGH AT HIM.